toujours dans l'actualité ouverture ce
matin du salon eco prises un salon
réservé aux représentants des comités
d'entreprise un salon organisé au palais
des congrès alors que le gouvernement
vient d'annoncer des mesures pour
faciliter les vacances des salariés des
précisions avec michel vial
conséquence logique du plan de rigueur
et des restrictions budgétaires pour les
voyages à l'étranger les touristes
devraient être cette année plus nombreux
que jamais en france d'où la campagne
lancée hier par le secrétariat d'état au
tourisme pour convaincre que les
vacances en france ne sont pas forcément
une punition pour développer les
capacités d'hébergement et multiplier
les services de promotion des richesses
touristiques nationales cette campagne
est également destinée à mieux mettre en
valeur l'apport économique du tourisme
l'un des secteurs d'activité toujours en
bonne santé et assurer l'accès de tous
aux vacances
parmi eux et avec les associations
touristiques et les différents
prestataires de services les comités
d'entreprise seront donc à même de faire
connaître l'ensemble des informations
relatives à cette campagne et à l'un de
ses atouts majeurs le chèque vacances
le chèque vacances est l'une des grandes
innovations
mises en place en 1983 et qui devrait
permettre un nombre progressivement très
élevé de salariés de bénéficier d'une
aide financière supplémentaire
permettant donc de réduire ce handicap
que constitue l'obstacle financier dans
l'accès aux vacances et par conséquent
au fur et à mesure que le chèque
vacances complété par des initiatives en
matière d'information touristique avec
leur concours de l' agence nationale
d'information touristique en particulier
doré permettre au comité d'entreprise et
à l'ensemble des salariés bénéficiant
des services des comités d'entreprise de
mieux préparer leurs vacances
s'il est trop tard pour améliorer
l'étalement des vacances et si les
grandes migrations estivales de 83
ressemble aux précédentes il restera au
moins un effort de promotion sans égale
du patrimoine touristique nationale une
bonne base de réflexion pour l'année
prochaine